hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 13 video
probably one of the best Carol Daryl
episodes in a long time I mean Carol and
Daryl always some of my favorite
characters but this episode they just
had so many great moments it was so
funny for both scary and funny reasons
just a quick reminder there's a new
round of the giveaway now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video there's
only three episodes left so I might do
something a little bit different for the
finale I probably gonna do a bigger
giveaway for that I mean it's a big
freakin deal so just careful for
spoilers from the episode as we get into
the top five moments starting with
number five Rick Carol and Daryl are
planning the takeover I love how Carol
buried so many bullets in that Walker
she's like well I'm supposed to be
practicing I shouldn't come back with a
full clip she is so on point Rick always
seems like the leader but Carol really
seems like the one that's doing all the
planning and if it wasn't cleared they
haven't told the rest of the group about
their plan the rest of the survivors
it's just the three of them as the
episode got on you could kind of tell
that they were starting to change their
mind I mean it seems like it's going in
that direction but we still have a
couple more episodes so we'll see if
things go downhill which they probably
will it wouldn't be the Walking Dead if
things didn't go to [ __ ] by the end of
the season on to number 4 Sasha is
slowly going crazy lots of great Sasha
montages especially when she was using
those family pictures for target
practice she just she can't stand life
in this community she thinks it's all a
big fiction she's still experiencing the
trauma of losing Tyreese you could argue
that Daryl's going through the same
thing but he lost his brother and dealt
with it during season four so he just
had more time to process and she
actually enjoyed a big easter egg from
the comics so in the Alexandria safe
zone the clock tower is a really notable
place in the comics it's Andrea that
ends up using it so I guess you could
argue that Sasha is going to be the
Andrea inside the Alexandria safe zone
or at least get all the big Andrea
action moments it seemed like early on
in season 5 when they were dealing with
the hunters that she was headed in that
direction
so this is just a little more
confirmation I know there's always
questions about like who's gonna be
Andrea from the comics so now it kind of
looks like we can point to Sasha the
interesting thing is that in the comics
- Andrea gets tied up with Douglass's
son Spencer so they aren't sticking
pretty close to the comics I mean it'd
be relatively close
Douglass's son in the comics just was
like trying to push up on Andrea and she
wasn't having any of it
so just open up a tab for the clock
tower with the rifle in it and those two
characters Spencer and Sasha they will
be important later moving out to number
three Rick and Jesse kind of start a
little bit of a thing it's kind of hard
to tell where she's coming from she just
seems really friendly she's not openly
hitting on him I think she likes a lot
of things about him and wants to get to
know him a lot better and Rick likes the
idea of her she represents the kind of
life that I would like to have after
this is all over after the apocalypse is
over so I think both of them are just
attracted to each other because of what
they represent they are two really
good-looking people so there's that
going on and it's only implied but
Jesse's husband is a little short with
her they're gonna they're gonna develop
that we'll learn a little bit more about
him but he is the town doctor which is
actually kind of a problem you get a
sense that there's going to be a
conflict between him and Rick at some
point especially with the [ __ ] that's
developing between him and Jesse but if
he's the doctor and he dies like if Rick
ends up killing him or or something bad
ends up happening to him they'll be down
a skilled physician which is really bad
to be fair they have gotten on the
survivors have gotten on without a
doctor so they'll probably be okay the
rest of the people in the community not
so much
they'll probably flip their [ __ ] the
weird thing about the Walking Dead is
there's not a whole lot of sex on it not
as much as you think given all the
violence in the gore and the fact that
it's on cable I mean think about it real
hard if it were the apocalypse and you
were just trying to survive you'd
probably have sex with the first woman
you came across just to relieve some
tension but like we saw when they first
met Rick you know lost his mind whenever
he thought he lost Carl and Judith he
just been so preoccupied so far that it
hasn't been the first thing on his mind
but now that they're in the safe zone
things are calming down his mind is
starting to wander to her cash and
prizes who among us could not say we
would not do the same thing you could
totally make all the Shane jokes she
want like he's totally putting the moves
on some other dudes wife he is kind of
ashamed but Shane was a lot more willing
to sacrifice members of the group that's
the big difference between Rick and
Shane that yeah they're relatively
similar people but R it really is a good
person deep down inside it's just when
you push him over the edge
try to rape his son that he bites a
chunk out of your neck and goes crazy
but I think we're all in agreement that
what's going on between the three of
them Rick Jesse and Pete who's who's
Jesse's husband is gonna do something
something's gonna happen to push Rick
over the edge don't be surprised that
they use that is the Cline
that pushes into the finale like the big
WTF finale there's some comic book
moments that we can tie to that but but
I'll explain after my top five moments
with a special spoiler warning just in
case you don't want to know about the
comics moving on to number two though
Darrel bonds with Aaron over buttons as
much as Carol was my favorite thing in
this episode Daryl was like my second
favorite for like non WTF reasons just
because it's so fun watching an outdoor
cat slowly become an indoor cat if you
want to tie it back to the claimers
again claimed I felt like using buttons
the horse was it was a very effective
emotional tool he can call Scott Gimple
and the other Walking Dead writers
manipulative but it totally worked it's
like it's an audience like you feel so
wounded just because Daryl admires this
horse so much and then you watch it just
get torn apart by walkers you're just so
sad why don't you come in have some
spaghetti cry on our shoulders and look
here's something to make you feel better
here's a bike that you can put back
together it really feels like the show
is pushing Aaron is one of the same
people inside the safe zone like they
want us to think that he's gonna make it
as part of the survivors regardless of
what goes down in the finale like
there'll be a group that will survive
into season six I think that they just
they want us to think that Aaron is
worthy of being a survivor as opposed to
the other crazier members of the safe
zone like Deanna for instance isn't that
just something that they would do before
they get ready to kill someone though so
I guess we should all worry for Aaron's
safety but I am hoping that he makes it
into season six because he's a really
interesting character I don't think that
anything he was doing with Daryl like
trying to get him to go out and be one
of the recruiters was manipulative at
all I think that was completely genuine
a key sense that Daryl just doesn't work
so well full-time inside the community
but he also doesn't belong outside so he
needs to be able to go in and out as he
pleases and my number one WTF moment of
course Carol is the scariest person
inside the safe zone right now you can a
pick all the cookies in the world or be
I'll let you die a horrible death
outside the safe zone and your mother
will never find out what happened to you
in case you forgot Sam is one of Jesse's
children when it Jesse's two children so
when he said I tell my mother everything
that was actually a really positive
thing like she seems like a really good
mom Carol also really good mom for very
different
reasons I like the idea that she's a den
mother she called herself a den mother
she really is but she's the den mother
of like the most dangerous children in
the world like Sasha for instance you
can think of her as one of her cubs
looks like she's getting ready to go off
like a nuclear bomb and Carol Carol is
just stone cold all those comments
though about the about the cookies the
the applesauce and the chocolate that's
for real though people do put applesauce
and cookies
my favorite moment though during that
whole scene was when he first was like
I've followed you I thought you're gonna
make more cookies I thought that she was
actually gonna kill him at the end of
the episode didn't you just feel it was
gonna be like a look at the flowers
moment like oh well I gotta kill him now
he saw me there's nothing else we can do
about it that's why I love the walking
dead so much because this is like a
really evil moment there's something
really evil for Carol to do but you
cheer so hard because you love Carol so
much it's the same thing with Rick's
character too like when he totally goes
off the reservation you just you cheer
so loud that's actually a really good
jumping-off point here's my big question
for you guys what is your favorite evil
thing that one of the survivors has done
like definitely cross the line bad thing
to do but it made you cheer really hard
I would say before this it was like the
end of season 4 when Rick bit out the
claimers Nick Carol's cookies now though
is my number one definitely number one
it's gonna be hard to top this
Rick killing Pete might be a good one
but I still feel like Carol's cookies is
gonna go down is like one of the season
5 moments mark my words
whenever they gets a Comic Con they do
like their Walking Dead panel they'll
probably have like a cookie moment just
like they had a Karl pudding moment last
year do you hear that AMC marketing just
make a whole bunch of cookies that is
your new marketing strategy for Comic
Con this summer just explain the comic
book stuff is just around the corner
like with the the W markings and the
scavengers so the scavengers are a group
that are in and around the DC area in
the comics they didn't debut till issue
number 75 but they tie in with
Alexandria safe zone story so I'm just
gonna put this spoiler tag up for a
second so here we go
so the scavengers want what's inside the
safe zone they don't find out about it
they don't find where it is until Rick
kills Pete like he kills Pete it makes
this big sound and it alerts the
scavengers where the safe zone is and it
leads to a big conflict right off the
bat that just sounds like something they
would do for the finale so maybe
we'll see like some crazy Rick Pete
moment in episode 15 maybe even episode
14 but then there was this Morgan Street
Easter Egg
so maybe Morgan is gonna show up as that
all goes down to I'm kind of hoping we
see Jesus before next season we haven't
met him we haven't seen him inside the
safe zone but he is a safe zone
character it's possible that like like
with negan they're holding him for
season six so given how close we are to
the finale I'm just expecting the
scavengers to be like the next big
villain group you guys can let me know
if you agree though just let me know do
you think that negan's gonna show up as
part of the scavengers group or do you
think it's just gonna be scavengers and
then after they're dealt with later in
season six will see negan so I'll pose
the Q&A for this tomorrow I'll announce
the giveaway winner be sure to subscribe
to get that if you haven't already but
since I forgot to list the winner of my
Game of Thrones giveaway this week in my
Game of Thrones video earlier today I'll
say Misha Houston you win the Game of
Thrones Season 4 DVD just be sure to
message me on the back end of my channel
for a contact info I'm sure everyone has
questions about what's going on with
Rick and Jesse what's going on with
Sasha slowly losing her mind
Michonne putting her katana up Daryl
totally broen out with Aaron so many
good things in this episode there's so
many things we could talk about so while
you guys wait for that Q&A you can click
here for the Game of Thrones video I
just posted the game Thrones Season 5
video and you can click here for all my
other Walking Dead Season 5 videos thank
you so much watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow now let's all do the thing
you